ufc what's what's that next big night
uh style bender versus uh polycosta
and that's in uh ufc uh fight island it
in
abu dhabi yeah jesus christ why don't
they just do
why do they do abu dhabi and not ve just
keep it in vegas
for the international fight fighters so
they'll have to fly all the way to vegas
because like
style better israel is in new zealand he
flies there to easier flight
uh for polo costa brazil it's easier
there so
so who do you got in that fight uh
israel i think it's a perfect fight for
him
he could do his [ __ ] yeah yeah he he
does well against aggressive guys
but ufc is popping popping yeah fights
all the time
big fights then you got the dana white
contender series it's good during the
week
and they're crushing it man are you
watching the contendership i haven't
been watching it's good
why is it good because were you an
ultimate fighter fan
yes so if you like like if you're an
actual hardcore fan it's
just like these guys are legit fighters
like i think last night there's this
russian dude versus brazilian dude
the russian dude is like 14-0 brazilian
dudes 15-0
and they're fighting for a ufc contract
that night so these boys come to
fight they're like fighting there's no
there's no it's not like you know where
the
the ultimate fire there's a buildup of
characters guys weren't very good
they're just
that's how you were i found you yeah but
these guys are like
fighting fighting they're coming to
fight because if they win that fight
they get a contract that night dana goes
yeah here's the contract
so these boys are scratching i have to
watch it how many of them
and they also have like the what's who's
who who's the girl that i like laura
senko laura sanchez
they have she's like the she comes into
the ring but she also does commentary
like she's like a mvp of that thing
she's a beast okay so i'm hoping they
take her and implant her into the actual
ufc production
is this chick right here she could fight
she was a fighter too she well she was a
fighter but she's a commentator now okay
okay she's
by far i think the mvp of the contender
series okay
because you want the whole production
thing is really good but she's like
one of the best things that's dope and
what uh what about my man khabib
like if you're a fighter and how old is
kabi uh
30 was he 32 don't you as a fighter
like think like i need to fight 32 it's
been
how long has it been since he [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of conor mcgregor
it's been almost two years two years
well it's fought no no
it's over a year let's see it's like a
year it's year and it's like we fought
dustin pourier
right mm-hmm september 2019. that was
his last fight
abu dhabi i forgot then his father
passed away okay which was a big
deal and he but he had that one fight
that got cancelled with tony ferguson
right two times multiple times right
another issue that was a covet thing
right
right okay and then now he's fine don't
you get antsy wouldn't you be antsy to
fight
how do you keep yourself yeah how do you
keep yourself like
fight ready because but these guys it's
not like you could practice can you
practice no but you can never you could
stay in shape right yeah
but he also right so ramadan right he's
super
right his religion so the muslim
religion so ramadan so he can't fight
during that time
which is what august i think and then
his father passed away so he's dealing
with that
he promised he only has two fights left
he wants to retire 30-0 he's 28 no now
so then he has his yeah oh i'm sorry
ramadan is april 12th to
you don't want to [ __ ] that up no do not
get that correct people
get it right so you know he has a lot of
other x factors going on but his father
passed away he's the biggest deal okay
but then
he and then also i think they're good
maybe do it at the apec center in vegas
but when they do fight when he fights
justin gaichi
stylishkey it's his toughest test to
date it's a
why gaichi is just a [ __ ]
heavy-handed great wrestling great
cardio can go all five rounds
just beat the brakes off tony ferguson
right beat the [ __ ] out
right right right and then you know and
he's more active so like it's a tough
fight for khabib man
and then already you know the [ __ ]
fans worked like oh khabib vs
gsp it's like dude he has to get through
this gsp
leave it leave it alone i know gsp needs
to leave it alone i know
crazy leave it why are we is he not
having money
he has money then why are you still
fighting he doesn't look right and he's
39 and he'd have to cut to
uh 55. while out you're done
you think you should be done he should
be done he don't look right like
he gets when he was young he would beat
his hair out
no but i'm saying like one of the last
two fights he had i mean he was in there
like
i'm like you're supposed to be he looked
thick against michael bismay it didn't
it wasn't
good no didn't look like i and i think
if he were to cut to 55 he
it'd be a problem for him especially
fight kabib at 55. no it's a bad idea
don't do that and conor says he's done
done now well you know how connor is
if if gaichi wins i bet they do conor uh
gaichi
because it's a good it's a better
matchup for conor he doesn't want khabib
it's a tougher fight but he does want he
that's all he's holding out for is the
winner of khabib gaichi
that he's like i'm going to fight he
[ __ ] him up
yeah he [ __ ] him up he did and he
didn't
if you look at the house so because like
you know if you're balls deep connor fan
which i am
like he barely he really didn't train
his takedown defense connor didn't train
whose fault is that what you're fighting
a guy but it's his but imagine him with
a full camp
but also his takedown defense was pretty
[ __ ] good
yes i mean he's sick but when he had him
in that [ __ ] bear claw oh i
know
but give him a full camp like there's
hope
there's always hope but there's hope if
gate you were to be
khabib gaichi does not in it does not
partake in takedowns doesn't want to do
it doesn't take anybody down
he'll sit and trade with connor that's
what connor [ __ ] lives for
so if you're a connor fan you want him
to get the belt the easiest pathway
which isn't easy but if you're a connor
fan
would be if gates you were to win and
what did conor gates and what about
um jones isn't he fighting is
heavyweight
he's going to go up to heavyweight who's
he going to fight uh
he'll fight uh stipe right away so i bet
he waits to
step and francis fighting to fight the
winner of that stipe's the guy who just
beat dc right yes
now i said something that people got so
[ __ ] offended i want to throw this i
can't wait
i said cause joe rogan and the ufc and
we've been talking about this since i
first came on the show
i said about ronda rousey i said how can
you say anyone's the greatest
of all time that's what we do the
greatest of all time and she's literally
never taken a punch and as soon as she
took a punch
the first time rhonda got punched done
game over
okay now people say dc the greatest of
all time
the greatest of all time choose your
words carefully now let me choose my
word you're in sparta
choose your words carefully i will kick
it i just had dc on my show that's my
guy
i [ __ ] training partners i [ __ ] with
dc but he's lost
big fights but he's one big fight i know
but and then you can how could you say
the greatest of all time you could say
let me one of
if you say one of i'm cool with it well
they should say one of them they don't
they say
that's nothing but that's that's like
lebron
but they'll say steepy like they were
like the rogan said before
the greatest heavyweight of all time
yeah and i'm like okay so is steep be
the greatest heavyweight of all now he
is
but no he's the champion no he's the
greatest of all time
yeah well he let me educate you on dc
for a second so you know
let me do a favor i i i said that he's
one of
yeah but what he was fighting for if he
if he were to beat stephen he would ride
off in the sense that is the grace to
ever do it
because but after the last loss when he
got [ __ ] the [ __ ] knocked out of him
it's like but he was winning all the
rounds and then
and then but before that he knocked him
out i was there one and one
i got it and then he didn't fight him
again no no
he didn't what was that dude's name who
the dude who knocked him out
who knocked two l who knocked out dc jon
jones
no no no no no he's only lost to jon
jones and stephen jon jones twice
we don't know what he was on or not on
allegedly because
but he lost those fights i don't know
why john's the grace of all time
that's what i'm saying and then when
john goes to heaven he'll be the
greatest fault nun that's what nobody's
beating john
so why so why like because john hasn't
got a heavyweight yet but as of right
now for heavyweight
you gotta realize dc was a light
heavyweight his entire career
fought in the in the in the force grand
prix fought the best of the best
won that and was the was the biggest
underdog
beat beat josh barnett bigfoot silva
beat the [ __ ] out of these dudes
goes to the ufc as a heavyweight beats
frank mayer beats roy jones
then goes to light heavyweight becomes
champion at light heavyweight beats
everybody not named jon jones right
b gus finn beat all these guys anthony
rumble johnson
and then goes to heavyweight knocks out
stephen right
gets the belt and then fights him twice
and loses
but when it for me when the it's always
time i just don't like that
the greatest the whole time
everything should be everything should
be one of i agree unless there's
you agree that in basketball too it's
hard to see
yes see it's a team sport so you're
saying like floyd mayweather
[ __ ] 49 you could say i mean in
his division he's the greatest of all
time whether you like him or not all
that [ __ ] personality
all that [ __ ] but i'm just saying like
in his division now you say oh is he
could he fight muhammad ali he's like
i'm not talking to you yeah that's right
you're stupid yeah i hate you you sound
stupid there's nothing worse you sound
dumb but but you know like with
individual sports i think you can
say it you can't argue
a heavyweight versus a flyweight but if
you argue heavyweight heavyweight this
is where the argument gets weird because
if you go steve is the greatest of all
times like well hold on
because stylistically kane velasquez
when he was in his prime
would give stipe all the problems to me
the if
they went you got to pick one guy that
would beat anybody in the world
and they're both would you say he's
ahead of velasquez is that the greatest
we've ever seen
okay so that's what i'm talking about
and if you talk to dc who came up with
kane their training partners and they're
both heavyweights
he would say cain velasquez that's what
i'm talking i just don't like that the
great
they're fighting it's inviting us
because nobody's saying it about
steeping
sales pay-per-views i understand it you
so you used to train with dc
yeah and stipe both of them jesus christ
like what like wrestling
everything like what would you do punch
spar wrestle like do what
yeah like right chill out like you do
what you know
just trying to get training like yeah
and you roll around yeah
but here's here's what's inside like
you're like you're on him
and he's on you yeah i'm getting into it
dude when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song